let's talk about how to answer questions
during the behavioral interview
welcome back to episode 16 of Udacity
career tips my name is Martin McGovern
and today we're gonna be diving into how
to prepare for the behavioral interview
and the questions that are coming your
way
the behavioral interview can be a
strange experience you're in a strange
office with strange people we're in a
strange suits and that strange desk with
a strange guy or gal staring at you
strangely they start off the
conversation with a barrage of questions
and the trouble soon begins tell me
about yourself
what are your strengths and weaknesses
and why do you want to work here don't
you wish you could just say hey my name
is Jerry please don't make me recite my
resume I'm too shy to talk about my
strengths and too insecure to really
share my weaknesses I want to work here
because I have to pay rent and you were
one of the only people that responded to
the thousands of applications that I
sent out there can I please have this
job no no no no no we really can't say
that it's too honest it's too specific
it's just a bit too much so most of us
end up going the other way way too vague
like this hey I'm a hard worker my
strength is that I work hard and my
weakness is that sometimes I work too
hard I want to work here because it
seems like a place that I can work hard
with other hard-working people let me
know about your decision I'm sure it's
gonna be a hard one this one's all the
way up in the clouds with how vague it
is and we got ourselves a real
Goldilocks situation here too hot too
cold we got to find out what's just
right and here's the answer what's just
right is giving real examples rather
than talking about anything theoretical
when answering these questions forget
your personal inner thoughts and please
don't use obscure generalities when
answering these questions you want to
talk about what has happened in your
life with concrete examples so if I were
to answer these questions here's how I
would do it hey there my name is Martin
and I help job seekers change their
careers by coaching them on the basics
of marketing and positive psychology
when it comes to strengths and
weaknesses my manager once complimented
me on my ability to wear many hats and
get the job done but it has also been
pointed out to me that I need to do a
better job of sharing the learnings from
this work more broadly within the
organization so that others can benefit
from what we're doing on this team the
reason I want to work at Udacity is
because you educate millions of people
all around the world and I would like to
help the job seekers within your classes
overcome their fears and get those new
careers breaking down this answer you
can see that I talked about the specific
work that I've done
to answer the first piece which is tell
me about yourself then I use actual
feedback I've received from a manager in
order to discuss my strengths and
weaknesses and finally I cite a
statistic about the company which shows
that I've done my research and know why
this is the company that I want to be at
at the end of the day when answering
interview questions
don't try to invent stories or get fancy
or beat around the bush just clearly
state what has happened why it matters
and how you can help the company in the
future now we're at the point of the
video where I put the challenge back to
you taking this framework how would you
answer these three questions add your
responses in the comments below
thank you for watching in order to
continue to get updates on these videos
please subscribe to us on YouTube and
hit the bell as well as follow us on
LinkedIn and you'll be on top of all be
new career videos that we're going to be
creating and sending your way if you
know anyone who's searching for a job
right now
tag them in the comments and let them
know you're thinking about them and we
wish you the best of luck in your job
search
take care